a steve jobs quote that the world is  made by people no smarter than you is  actually true and so if you're believing  that these people are smarter than you  because you did bad on your sats i'm  just going to tell you right now stop  so you can develop yourself so my  obsession became that humans are the  ultimate adaptation machine we are  literally wired from the ground up  in order to grow and improve under  stress and pressure so it's like what's  the phrase uh pressure can burst pipes  but it also creates diamonds so it's  like you need the pressure and yes it  can hurt but it can also make something  amazing if you're willing to put  yourself in that situation